[Music]
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam net from norway are
establishing a masjid a dawa center
establishing a masjid to convey the
message of islam is one of the best
deeds a muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in norway you know this and
i know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
allah azzawajal will give you even more
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing
many of you will be familiar with
this figure this individual who is
referred to now as the quran burner
because he's a one-trick pony
with the only ability that he has
demonstrated is the ability to turn on
the lighter
and to
put that flame onto paper uh very uh low
skill indeed
but this individual has recently made a
fumbling embarrassment of himself let's
take a look at the clip
as you can see this individual now
uh literally tossing and turning in his
vehicle it's like an army vehicle a
military-style vehicle
he's in the war whatsoever he's in fact
in some confrontation with a muslim
woman
and somehow his car
uh was fumbling and turning around in a
motorway just like he himself has been
fumbling and turning
up in different places in the muslim
community trying to attack them
the last time this individual was
coming out and burning the quran he
helped us raise 300 000
dollars you know for the for the raising
of for the building of a masjid in one
of the biggest in fact the biggest
message project in the whole of norway
and here he is in the months of
making a fool of himself
at our advantage once again
because of course it will be my time to
remind you
that this message project is no it's not
finished it's not complete yet
and we require
more donations in these very important
days the prophet muhammed told us
there's no
days
that good deeds are better than than
these 10 days
so they said well
not even struggling in the sake of allah
subhanahu ta'ala
the prophet muhammed
with his
wealth and his self and he didn't come
back so these 10 days oh kamakaza these
10 days are the most important
10 days in terms of doing good deeds
and this is my
uh
this is my opportunity to give this to
you obviously using this fumbling
buffoon
uh the quran burner as
some kind of a amusing incentive for for
all of us
at this special time
and if i were to give
the fumbling buffoon
who's impervious
to rational inquiry
and who is
an embarrassment to himself and his own
community one piece of advice
it would be the following
i would say look
forget about this facade of being a
military man
or an army general or something that
maybe you have some delusion of grandeur
you think you're some kind of crusader
or something like that forget about that
if it's a rational debate you're after
then the muslim community is ready
if it's some legal physical thing you're
after i'm sure
there are many
elderly gentlemen of your own age who
would oblige you in that as well
in the muslim community so just choose
what you're looking for and stop making
mockery of yourself and as for the rest
of us
it's our time to donate and for a masjid
what better thing can i bring you and
the prophet muhammad told us
the one who
the one who signals to the good is like
the one
who does the good wa
the
whoever builds a mosque for allah allah
will build for him a similar house in
jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
message
yes
that will be something that you'll have
on your scale